is there advice outside of love that you
can give to young people
you were a million years ago a professor
is there advice you can give to young
people high schoolers college students
about career about life yeah but it's
not they're not going to like it because
it's not easy to operationalize so and
this was a problem when I was a college
professor too people would ask me what
they should do should they go to
graduate school I had almost nothing
useful to say because the the job market
and the market of you know pre-job
training and all of that these things
are all so
distorted and corrupt that I didn't want
to point anybody to anything right
because it's all broken and I would tell
them that
but I would say that results in a kind
of uh meta level advice that I do think
is useful
you don't know what's coming
you don't know where the opportunities
will be
you should invest in tools rather than
knowledge right to the extent that you
can do things you can repurpose that no
matter what the future brings to the
extent that you know if you as a robot
guy right you've got the skills of a
robot guy now if
civilization failed and the stuff of
robot building disappeared with it
you'd still have the mind of a robot guy
and the mind of a robot guy can retool
around all kinds of things whether
you're you know forced to work with uh
you know you know fibers that are made
into ropes right your your Mechanical
Mind would be useful in all kinds of
places so invest in tools like that that
can be easily repurposed and invest in
combinations of tools right if
civilization keeps
limping along
you're going to be up against all sorts
of people who have studied the things
that you studied right if you think hey
computer programming is really really
cool and you pick up computer
programming guess what you just entered
a large group of people who have that
skill and many of them will be better
than you almost certainly
on the other hand if you combine that
with something else that's very rarely
combined with it if you have
I don't know if it's carpentry and
computer programming if you take
combinations of things that are even if
they're both common but they're not
commonly found together
and those combinations create a rarified
space where you inhabit it and even if
the things don't even really touch
but nonetheless they create a mind in
which the two things are live and you
can move back and forth between them and
you know step out of your own
perspective by moving from one to the
other
that will increase what you can see and
the quality of your tools and so anyway
that isn't useful advice it doesn't tell
you whether you should go to graduate
school or not but it does tell you the
one thing we can say for certain about
the future is that it's uncertain and so
prepare for it and like you said there's
cool things to be discovered in the
intersection of uh fields and ideas and
I would look at grad school that way
actually if you do go
or
I see I mean this is such a like every
course in grad school undergrad too was
like this little journey that you're on
that explores a particular field and and
it's not immediately obvious how useful
it is
but it allows you to to discover
intersections between that thing and
some other thing so you you're bringing
to the table this
these pieces of knowledge some of which
when intersected might create a niche
that's completely novel unique and will
bring you Joy I have that I mean I took
a huge number of courses in theoretical
computer science most of them seem
useless but they totally changed the way
I see the world uh in ways that are I'm
not prepared or is a little bit
difficult to kind of make explicit but
taken together
they've allowed me to see for example
the world of Robotics totally different
and different from many of my colleagues
and friends and so on and I think that's
a good way to see if you go to grad
school as
um
as a opportunity to explore
intersections of fields even if the
individual Fields seem useless yeah and
useless doesn't mean useless right
useless means not directly applicable
not directly a good useless course can
be the best one you ever took
um yeah I took uh James Joyce uh course
on James Joyce and that was truly
useless
well I took uh I took immunobiology in
the medical school when I was at Penn as
uh I guess I would have been a freshman
or a sophomore I wasn't supposed to be
in this class
it blew my goddamn mind and it still
does right I mean we had this I don't
even know who it was but we had this
great Professor who was like highly
placed in the world of immunobiology you
know the course is called immunobiology
not Immunology
immuno biology it had the right focus
and as I recall it
professors stood
sideways to the chalkboard staring off
into space literally stroking his beard
with this bemused look on his face
through the entire lecture and you know
he had all these medical students who
were so furiously writing notes that I
don't even think they were noticing the
person delivering this thing but you
know I got what this guy was smiling
about it was like so what he was
describing you know adaptive immunity is
so marvelous right that it was like
almost a privilege to even be saying it
to a room full of people who were
listening you know but anyway yeah I
took that course and you know lo and
behold
yeah Suddenly It's front and center and
wow my glad I took it but um anyway yeah
useless courses are great and actually
Eric
gave me one of the greater pieces of
advice at least for college that
anyone's ever given which was don't
worry about the prereqs
take it anyway all right but now I don't
even know if kids can do this now
because the prereqs are now enforced by
a computer but back in the day
if you didn't mention that you didn't
have the prereqs nobody stopped you from
taking the course and what he told me
which I didn't know was that often the
advanced courses are easier in some way
the materials complex
but you know you know it's not like
intro bio where you're learning a
thousand things at once right it's like
focused on something so if you dedicate
yourself you can you can pull it off
yeah stay with an idea for many weeks at
a time and it's ultimately rewarding and
not as difficult as it looks yeah